got a right triangle and you're dropping
an altitude okay to the hypotenuse okay
so that these are both right angles and
what we end up with is three triangles
one two and overall triangle three
triangles that are all similar to one
another because the corresponding angles
are congruent so the sides are going to
be proportional so what comes out of
that is is that we've got two formulas
here we have the leg okay leg one is the
geometric mean okay of the hypotenuse
which is this whole length okay times
the part of the hypotenuse that's
adjacent to that leg that's closest to
that leg so these are the means these
are the extremes and the leg one is the
geometric mean of the hypotenuse this
whole hypotenuse and a part of the
hypotenuse that's closest to that leg
when we look at leg number two here so
this is the leg of the overall right
triangle this leg two is the geometric
mean of the entire hypotenuse and the
part of the hypotenuse B that's closest
to that leg so I'll show you in some
examples how you work with this so say
for example this one here we have that
right triangle we drop the altitude we
have three triangles that are similar to
one another okay and the leg here which
is X okay is our geometric mean so
here's our geometric mean okay these are
the means of the entire hypotenuse which
is 9 and the part of the hypotenuse
that's closest to that leg so we want
four we don't want this length here so
that's 4 we cross multiply we get x
squared equals 36 and if we take the
square root we get 6 so that's the
length of the leg of the overall right
triangle okay let's go to the next
example same thing we have a right
triangle we drop in altitude we get
three similar triangles and we can use
our leg geometric mean theorem so this
leg Y okay is the geometric mean of the
entire hypotenuse which here we're going
to have to add these two pieces together
nine times the part of the hypotenuse
that's adjacent to that leg so that's
six so if you cross multiply you get Y
squared equals 54 take the square root
of both sides
you get three square root of six once
you simplify that radical last example
okay here they give us the leg is ate
the entire hypotenuse is 10 and we're
trying to find this part that's adjacent
to this leg here so same idea we've got
eight is the leg that's the geometric
mean of the entire hypotenuse that's 10
and the part of the hypotenuse X that's
adjacent to that leg so you can see this
is 10 x equals 64
divide both sides by 10 x equals 6.4